the economy and regeneration team work  to help bring new employment  opportunities to the district as well as  sustaining existing jobs we do this by  planning regeneration of town centers  and enabling development of new  employment sites one way we can achieve  this is by using council own land and  buildings to help facilitate both large  and small employment opportunities an  example is the project currently taking  place at Broadmeadow in Timoth where  we're working with a large supermarket  chain to deliver a scheme that provides  much-needed sports pitches for the  community employment land for  development and providing new jobs for  the people to the town to find out more  about our service why not visit us  online